1,5 Milliarden D-Mark damals für
die DDR 1983 da sind die noch
mal sechs Jahre lang mit Aussicht
kommen mit 17 Millionen Insassen
da können sie mal sehen wie ordentlich die da
gewirtschaftet haben sozialistische Misswirtschaft
habe ich bitte Sie das sind halt 750 Millionen
Euro das reicht mir der Hypo Realistin
die DDR war pleite haben wir da gelacht war
für mich mit den Griechen und den Amerikaner
weil die DDR solide finanzierter Staat schauen
Sie bitte wenn die Staatsverschuldung an von
damals und was wir heute haben das war einfach
nur lächerlich es geht ja gar nicht darüber viel
Schulden sie haben die Leute wollen ihr Geld gar
nicht zurück haben die ihnen das Geld geliehen
haben die wollen Zinsen wie viel Schulden sie
haben interessiert doch keine Sorgen das hatte
alles nicht mehr vernünftig zu tun meine Damen
und Herren die Griechen haben pro Kopf 26000 €
startschulden die Amerikaner pro Kopf 30 000 €
startschulen und jetzt hat Barack Obama einen
haushaltspunkt vorgestellt für seine Amtszeit in
den vier Jahren will er noch mal 15000 € Schulden
pro Kopf neu dazu machen das heißt dann haben
die Griechen hinter 27000 € Schulden pro Kopf
und die Amerikaner haben 45000 € Schulden pro
Kopf und wer ist kreditwürdig ja klar die Amis
den müssen Sie Geld leihen weil die haben
eine Armee die kommen sich da so ins holen
[Applaus] [Musik]
und die griechische Krise ist richtig dran
die müssen jetzt 10 Milliarden pro Jahr im
Haushalt einsparen verglichen bei uns werden
das 80 Milliarden pro Jahr stellen sie mal
für die Würde aus unserem Haus und 80 Milliarden
rausstreichen was hier los wäre und die Griechen
müssen sich daran halten wenn ich jetzt jedes
Jahr 10 Milliarden sparen dann gibt's richtig
Ärger was passiert eigentlich wenn ihr das nicht
schaffen ich glaube da müssen die Strafe zahlen
wovon Du das denn dann ich glaube
die Merkel wird den das Leihen ne
Barack Obama hat einen Haushalt aufgestellt
für seine vier Jahre Amtszeit können Sie
nachlesen hat gesagt im ersten Jahr mache
ich 1.600 Milliarden Dollar neue Schulden 1.6
so im zweiten Amsterdam mache ich noch mal 1.600
Milliarden Dollar neue Schulden im
dritten Amsterdam mache ich noch mal
1.600 Milliarden Dollar neue Schulden
und im vierten Amt hat er gesagt schön
ja er ist im vierten Jahr so lange braucht
der Körper fühlt und den Trick vorzubereiten
der schönste Gag ist wenn die sagen
die startschulden werden halbiert er
wird überhaupt nichts zurückbezahlt dann
glauben Sie ja da wird was zurückgezahlt
nein startschulden halbiert heißt
die neue Verschuldung wird halbiert
der Barack Obama verspricht er macht
im vierten Jahr seine Amtszeit nur
noch halb so viel neue Schulden wie jeweils in den
ersten drei Jahren so einen Diätplan
müsste man mit Ihrem Arzt aufstellen
sagen sie ich nehme auch im 4 Jahr noch nicht ab
aber ich nehme im 4 Jahr nur noch halb so viel
neu zu wie jeweils in den nächsten drei Jahren und
dann diskutiert die in der Medizin weil man hören
die Höhe der schönen spielt
keine Rolle die Frage ist ob
sie noch frisches Geld kriegen
um die Zinsen bezahlen zu können
ja klar und wenn die Amerikaner überhaupt nicht
mehr genug kreieren Geld wir drucken jetzt auch
Geld in der europäischen Währungszone Geld ohne
Ende seit zwei Jahren damals Geld gedruckt hätten
sie gesagt dass das Spiel Geld was wollen denn
damit die Amis drucken jetzt auch Spiegel der
Dollar ist fast gar nichts mehr wert nur sie
kaufen Ihre Altersvorsorge toll toll toll